one thing i'm curious about before we
get obviously into this amazing
sprawling vision what was your take when
you saw cavill's
uh cgi mustache removal
you must have seen that i mean i've
always i've only seen it in memes what's
up everyone i'm carlos bustamante for et
canada's nerd alert
while the nightmare sequence in zack
snyder's justice league is a welcome
addition for many fans
pretty much everyone can agree that the
real nightmare sequence
was this one from the justice league
theatrical cut does your thing really
stand for hope yes
it does but it looks like an s yes it's
meant to
it's it's meant to wind like a river
it comes and goes my
a man on you used to say that hope is
like a car keys
easy to lose if you dig around it's
usually close by
so what did zack snyder think of the
moment that birthed a million memes
in an interview with mtv's josh horowitz
zack admitted that he'd only seen that
footage
through memes as he's never seen joss
whedon's 2017 cut of the film
he added that he's happy the new version
can help clean up the legacy
of henry cavill superman it's sad to
think that
that would been the last view that
people had of superman was just that
whatever that is elsewhere in the
interview zack acknowledges that the
door may be closed for his vision of the
dc eu
but as with anything related to
superhero movies and especially with
this fandom
we know to never say netflix warner
brothers
they've expressed no interest uh in
anything
you know more that i would have to
contribute you know the story
is a cliffhanger only because that's how
it was constructed it was always meant
to be that so
um but you know i didn't think i'd be
here talking to you now about
this version of justice league so who
knows but um
you know excited to see um
what jj's got in store for us so that's
fun
you